welcome to pftot on yahoo sports he's
peter king i'm mike florio big stories
in the nfl and obviously the build up to
super bowl 54. there's been a lot of
talk about who's going to win but peter
let's look at it from the perspective of
how many points will be scored currently
the over under is 54. do you anticipate
super bowl 54 being a high scoring game
i definitely i look i've not bet on an
nfl anything in forever
but last week i was telling people i
only know one thing about the afc
championship game bet the over and it
was closer than i thought it would be i
thought it'd even be more high scoring
than it was and i would say the same
thing on this one for a very simple
reason
healthy patrick mahomes is nearly
impossible to hold down
and
uh i think the 49ers you know with their
ability to run the ball
and and i am one who basically says
this 49ers game planning and running it
75 of the time in these two playoff
games
i believe that kyle shanahan is going to
spend the next x number of days pumping
up jimmy garoppolo and making sure that
he is a major factor in the super bowl
so in my opinion i think both teams are
going to be able to i'm not saying
you know perform at will but i think
both teams are going to have very strong
offensive days in super bowl 54.
see my concern as it relates to whether
or not the game will be high scoring is
that the 49ers may try to do what the
titans looked like they were going to be
able to do they had that nine minute and
four second drive in the second quarter
when they extended the lead from 10 to
seven to 17 to seven and there was a
moment there where it's like oh boy
it's almost gonna be like the third
quarter of super bowl 25 when the giants
had the ball the whole time right that
you keep patrick mahomes on the sideline
and you chew up the clock you shorten
the game you reduce the number of
possessions i feel like the 49ers could
maybe pull that off and if they're
inclined to try to do it that's what's
going to drive the scoring under that
number that's what makes me think that
maybe peter it won't be high scoring if
they adopt that philosophy and grind it
out grind it out grind it out shorten
the game and keep mahomes off the field
mike that has to be
robert salah's concern and and uh and
kyle shanahan's concern i mean
the san francisco 49ers right now would
sign for the kansas city chiefs only
getting nine or ten possessions
and and that would be the absolute
optimum way to try to win this game
because
you know i'll never forget and i've told
this story 100 times but
when the new york giants were heading in
to play the high-flying buffalo bills
uh in the 1990s super bowl after the 90
season
uh you know bill parcell said to ron
ehrhardt his offensive coordinator the
giants didn't have a great offense he
said to ron ehrhardt play clock ball in
other words
limit the possessions
for the buffalo bills and that's exactly
what they did the bills only had the
ball for 19 minutes in that super bowl
and the giants ended up squeaking one
out and that has to be on the minds of
both uh kyle shanahan and jimmy
garoppolo going into this game if i'm
the 49ers as often as possible i am
snapping the ball when the play clock is
at five four and three
yeah i agree with you completely and if
that happens it's going to be harder and
harder to get to 54. so that'll be a
very important thing to keep an eye on
for super bowl 54 will the 49ers try to
chew the clock will it work and will
they keep the chiefs scoring down and
will they necessarily have their own
scoring reduced we'll be back again next
week from miami with more pft ot on
yahoo sports videos from super bowl 54.
enjoy the week and we'll talk to you
soon
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports